I want to ask you about your wife in  this dress and she gorgeous  she looks great all right in front of me  Melissa McCarthy stunned in this custom  creation she co designed for saturday's  premiere of ghostbusters in LA  her hubby Ben Falcone was clearly  impressed by her look but more  importantly by her performance in the  film are you though of her and this  movie and what they did and especially  you start way back in the backlash and  people saying oh ghostbusters you can't  put women in ghosts well I just think  that's dumb is what I think and you know  I Paul Feig is a friend and he's a  really really smart person and he chose  the funniest people he could think of  and they happen to be women so you know  I have no problem with it I think  everybody out here today would say I  think you're wrong to the three people  and their mothers basements that said we  couldn't do it I think we did it